what inspired you to do some rock music
though was it just like this the [ __ ] I
like I want to try it
I love rock music bro alternative rock
Pennywise Sugar Ray like I said before
um I love Pennywise all kind of um
Nickelback I love you left Nickelback
blink 182. God Nickelback so gay
[ __ ] I love I even like of course AC DC
[ __ ] Nirvana The White Stripes yeah
White Stripes choir this is all good
bands look Nickelback's got hits I
forgot as my friend jelly roll says
Nickelback still [ __ ] their music [ __ ]
I love rock bro country I [ __ ] a country
too yeah I like country Luke Bryan I
like what's is that the fat guy what's
the fat guy Luke Combs he's funny
yeah um um [ __ ] Luke Holmes what song
did he don't tell me um
um some things go better together I like
the one about the long neck cold beer
never broke my heart oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah Better Together by Luke Combs is
hard too though and um
a lot of people like Morgan Wallen I
don't know who the [ __ ] that is he's the
guy who did the song with little Dirk oh
see he's one of them type of [ __ ] he's
like not a real country [ __ ] he's like
a he is oh for real but he's but he's
still [ __ ] with that rap shot that's
cool he grew up like listening to like
you know and then there's like guys like
jelly roll who make country but they
came from the right I like jelly roll I
don't know I don't I can't name a song
but I like jelly roll great guy jelly
roll is cool yeah super good guy uh what
else do you got coming besides the rock
project the sugar-free project
sugar-free project we're doing like a
lover boy project
um some rock we might do we might do
some country but we might do a country
rap project [ __ ] I'm just trying to
[ __ ] just get all the hit all the
Avenues of the [ __ ] that I like jazz we
might [ __ ] around with that I'm just
trying to mix it all the way up I'm not
just trying to stay in one pocket I want
to have fun how do you think your fans
would react to you doing a country album
this is the thing
it's one thing to stick to your cult
following and give them what they want
and feed them what they need which I
always will and then there's one thing
to venture out and do things for
yourself and just see what other avenues
are out there for yourself musically
right you feel what I'm saying and you
drop at such a high rate that even if
you put something out that you're like
cult fans are like what the [ __ ] you'll
be like don't worry I got your [ __ ]
coming don't worry I'm gonna throw the
Dickie suit on [ __ ] I'm I'm yeah I'm
still here you feel me I might bring out
the guitar with the straw hat but then
they gotta throw that [ __ ] right away
and [ __ ] jump right into the converse
[ __ ]